if you do talk about the Palestinian
people and their rights and the plight
of the Palestinians yeah then you are
connected to humas and then all of a
sudden you're connected to this is a
terrorist organization and that it
doesn't matter about those people yeah
the narrative is support of Israel
equals you're on the right side yeah
yeah that regardless of how their
policies impact individual human beings
through no fault of their own just
happen to be born Palestinian and been
stuck in this apartheid
[Music]
state I love you all the work that
you're do when I was ready to talk about
it I would only talk to I was explaining
how much respect I have for the faith of
his welcome to the show the
show how you doing alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah personally blessed but but
obviously aching for the um and the
tremendous Injustice that we're
witnessing that unfortunately is is
funded and supported by our tax dollars
and enabled by our politicians so really
really to be honest um enraged you know
I think enraged is the right word uh
personally blessed but we have to use
our blessings to demand an end to the
horrific Injustice and crimes against
humanity that our country the United
States is funding and enabling when you
say money now some people um don't
understand how much how much exactly are
the American
taxpayers putting out yearly for this
billions of dollars a year billions and
billions of dollars a year it's a
ridiculous amount that could be better
spent here at home instead it's it's
given to Israel to purchase weapons of
death that are used against unarmed
civilians that are maming children that
are making children orphans that are
cutting women and babies into pieces
defense ESS harmless women and children
are being killed in the thousands with
our tax dollars and meanwhile those the
the the money we're giving them is
actually being paid right back to the
United States merchants of death to
corporations that profit billions of
dollars from selling these weapons
without a care in the world and this is
what people have to wake up to the
powers that be they don't care about you
or me they don't care about Jews or
Christian or Muslims what they care
about is power wealth money land so the
people in Israel I mean it's no doubt
about it you can see the quotes and I'll
send you the quotes maybe we can put
them up on the screen of Israeli
leadership talking about eradicating the
Palestinians wiping out Gaza this isn't
new as a result of the attacks this
conflict did not start two weeks ago
they had longterm
plans of driving the Palestinians out
and the reason they have to is is that's
the only way their so-called Jewish
State can remain a Jewish State and have
any semblance of democracy because
essentially the land in Palestine or
Israel whatever you want to call it
especially if you include the occupied
territories of the West Bank in Gaza the
majority of the inhabitants have lived
there for generations for over a
thousand years and they are Palestinians
two former American vessels carrying
nearly 4,000 Jewish refugees arrive at
the Port of hia Palestine jammed like
cattle on the rusty craft the fugitives
end their Bleak Voyage which began at a
Black Sea port and we went from Italy to
Palestine it was not Israel yet it was
Palestine yeah what how did you get you
went by boat by boat we went to Israel
when Israel was not Israel yet two they
outnumber the
colonizing uh IM European immigrants
that came over the last 75 years
the colonizing European immigrants that
came over the last 75 year years that
identify as Jews and as israelies as
zionists they're a minority but they
want to control the land and how can you
as a minority control the land and still
call yourself a democracy unless you
basically make uh the other second class
citizens where their life is not as
equal as yours where they don't have a
wot a vote where you can kill them with
impunity so the point people have to
understand is by its design Israel needs
to get rid of the millions of
Palestinians there and that is their
open stated goal and that is why they
are terrorizing them this is Terrorism
America right now is the biggest funer
of terrorism and that's why the
hypocrisy just blows the mind because
you have two you you have Hamas which is
labeled as a designated terrorist
organization according to the US
government and then you have Israel but
if we Define terrorism as intentional
targeting of civilians or killing of
civilians to achieve a political goal
well Israel has done exponentially more
terrorism they've killed exponentially
more children they've killed
exponentially more
civilians than Hamas or any other
Palestinian group for that matter so yet
one is a designated terrorist
organization and another is funded by us
that's insane so the Israeli leadership
their goal is very clear they've been
wanting to drive the Palestinians out
because Israel cannot remain both a true
democracy and a Jewish State because if
it becomes a true democracy most of the
people that are not Jewish they're going
to remove all the laws that give special
unique rights and privileges to the to
the Jewish population there everybody
will be treated equal they'll cease to
be a Jewish state so they want to drive
the Palestinians out to have control of
the land the merchants of death on the
US side they want to profit from the
billions of dollars that they're getting
in weapon sales this is not a conflict I
want people able to be very clear
because there's a lot of confusion out
there and it's unnecessary this conflict
is very simple this is not a conflict
between Muslims and Jews and I stand by
that very strongly this is not a Muslim
Jew thing this is not a Muslim Jew
conflict it has nothing to do with that
what this is a conflict between it's not
even a conflict this is atrocities
committed
by a nuclear powerful colonizing
superpower the halves those with the
power those with the money those with
the resources which they don't even have
independently they're subsidized by us
Americans but it's a it's it's
atrocities
by that the group which is in power and
the people that they are subjugating
they are occupying they're torturing
they're killing and in fact there's many
Jews God bless them that stand with us
many yeah against Israeli Injustice
you'll
find throngs of Jew Jewish people
standing with us in protest condemning
the atrocities Israel is committing
saying not in my name you don't find
masses of Muslims protesting in support
of Israel because Israel is not the
oppressed it is not the occupied it is
the oppressor it is the occupier so you
have many Jews God bless them standing
with us and as for the victims of this
conflict you have both Muslims and
Christians together that are getting
slaughtered and treated as second class
citizens Israel doesn't care care if
you're Muslim or Christian if you're
Palestinian they want you out and that
is why we've noticed over the last
couple weeks how many churches one of
the oldest churches in the world
bombed how many uh uh
hospitals you know Christians killed as
well so this is a conflict between those
who have power the extremist Israeli
Zionist funded by the US and those who
do not have power that are colonized be
they Muslim or Christian with many
Jewish allies standing in solidarity
with them we were listening to Joe Rogan
and now he's getting to see he's kind of
changed over the years he's changed his
position and Joe Rogan's also he got to
see many of these um IDF uh soldiers
there even there's even IDF soldiers who
are coming out I think it's a group
called breaking the silence have you
heard of them uh my special forces
infantry unit went to the Border we
approached towards pales I they can just
be controlled we can just keep them
indefinitely under military occupation
deny them rights deny them freedoms the
same ones that we cherish for ourselves
they don't have and it's not about
security it's about ideology we're IDE
ideologically committed to controlling
the entire land of Israel exclusively
for the Jewish people so this is
something that's really powerful when
you see them coming out these IDE of
soldiers and they're because they're
conscious is eating away at them you've
seen some of them saying I can't sleep
at night did you see somebody's giving
[Music]
testimony I have I have haunting images
coming to me nightmares of the
atrocities that they're doing so what
was your take on some of the things that
Joe Rogan was saying no I mean it's
incredible and more people need to hear
this you know it's interesting because
when you talk
about engaging with those who have
served in the
IDF there's really two
groups but they both say the same
thing any of them will
acknowledge that they either currently
or in
history uh had no care for the lives of
Palestinians that that Israel since its
Inception to this day has slaughtered
countless civilians there's a great
documentary I highly recommend called
tentura where you have these tentura
where you have these uh you know guys in
their 70s and their 80s uh or even older
speaking about when they were driving
the Arabs out and how they wiped out
entire Villages just massacred them the
difference is the people of
morality that are speaking out they
condemn it they're ashamed of what
they've done
and they are condemning Israel for its
war crimes against the Palestinian
people meanwhile in the tentura
documentary these guys are actually
celebrating it they're laughing about
how they massacred women and children to
create Israel the the the Israeli
soldiers who were establishing Israel to
begin with and people try to say This is
complicated it's not complicated and it
isn't an old conflict Muslims and Jews
have lived peacefully in Jerusalem in
Palestine for hundreds and hundreds of
years under Islamic rules yeah yeah how
do you go off on that because that's
another thing an attack that the uh
Muslims there they just want to wipe out
absolutely not all the all of the uh
Jews but it's a good point right talk
about that more but before before this
whole thing the Zionist came they were
living in peace and when when Saladin
conquered Jerusalem from the Crusaders
who slaughtered women and children the
Crusaders the Christian Crusaders
bragged about having blood to their
knees and the blood of innocent Muslims
when they conquered Jerusalem once and
conquered it back first of all he
allowed the Crusaders to go back in
peace he didn't exact Revenge that is
what Islam teaches and then he welcomed
like 70 Jewish tribes and families to
move in and live and they've lived
peacefully and we've continued to live
peacefully the the the people of
Palestine and Gaza they don't hate
Israelis because they're Jewish they
hate Israel because Israel keeps bombing
the light day Daylights out of them
literally massacring them killing them
Israeli soldiers can kill palestin
children with no repercussion I
represented T Abad this was all over the
national media International media he
was 15 years old at the time they beat
him to a pulp his face was purple and
blue swollen they beat him on camera
none of them were held accountable
that's the norm he got off easy thank
God they didn't kill him his cousin was
killed stabbed and burned alive by
Israeli settlers there was no
accountability for it so they don't hate
because they're Jewish this not again a
conflict between Muslims and Jews it's
just a people that are ressed and
occupied they just want Liberty as the
American saying says Give me liberty or
give me death here's the important Point
AB Ian one of the leaders of Israel he
himself
acknowledged he said Jews were treated
justly twice in all of history they fac
just treatment in the United States and
they faced just treatment under Muslim
rule that's a whole different discussion
just on its own the history corre how
the Jews they fled persecution to Muslim
lands their golden age in Spain
absolutely Inquisition is a great
example that what you just gave when the
Ottomans sent ships to save the Muslims
who again the extremist Christians were
butchering Muslims in Spain and they
were butchering
Jews and when the Ottomans sent ships to
save the Muslims and we're proud of this
the first people that they let on the
ship were Jews they said why are you
doing this they said they are our
citizens as well we will protect them
that's what Islam's about we have one
God you cannot honor the god you cannot
honor God if you dishonor his Creation
The Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he said I will be the advocate of the
Jew or Christian living under Muslim
rule that is oppressed by the Muslims so
this is a farce this is just something
that's so so far away from Facts it's
intentional it's intentional propaganda
so what they're trying to do is paint
Palestinian resistance movements and
just paint the Palestinian cause as oh
these Arabs these Muslims they just
don't like Jews and they want to kill
them because they're Jews and they want
to get rid of them no nothing could be
further from the truth they coexisted
and had been but the issue is now the
the Palestines have been occupied and
oppressed by Israel so the Muslims would
like to live together in peace with
their no problem with that absolutely
but now you see this flaunted like this
is the only democracy but then you have
how do you have people who are exiled
from there what was it in 1940 how many
750,000 they had the first NBA and then
how many people how many musl no right
to return to their Homeland yeah so they
can't so someone who's never visited he
has the right of return right so under
under the American under the only
democracy how does that work so right
now anyone who's Jewish in the world uh
has the right to go to Israel birth
right they call it and they will pay and
fly them out and give them this tour of
Israel fully paid for that you have
people who were driven from their homes
in Palestine Palestinians who have lived
there for hundreds and hundreds of years
uninterrupted who still have the title
to their homes but they're not able to
return even those that are living there
if you know family members are in West
Bank and Gaza and Jerusalem if they they
can't even visit each other and if they
do they're treated like second class
citizens they have to get special
permits they they line up through cages
Palestinians are treated like second
class citizens and you can go down the
list of all of the in
Humane one thing but then the rights
that one person gets and you can't I
mean that's why that's why people like
the person who was um uh Jimmy Carter
was there he called it AP partar State
that's it uh you had Nelson Mandela
called it a part he said it's worse it
was worse than what the
African-Americans were going through so
you have one set of law for the Zionist
there Jew the Zionist Jews and then you
have another set of inhumane rights for
you have streets like you have streets
literally different streets even
different roads job is actually to
maintain an aparte system very uh very
early on I understood that the rights
that the Jewish settlers have are not
the rights that the Palestinians have I
understood that I cannot touch a Jewish
settler if he is attacking a Palestinian
the best I can do is call a local police
department to come handle it like I
would do at home in Jerusalem so these
Jewish settlers that live in Kon are
living under the same rights that I live
in in Jerusalem but the Palestinian next
to them next house over next building
over sometimes next apartment over lives
under my rule my military rule and I can
do whatever I want with him I can take
his home as a temporary base for a few
hours to a few days to a few weeks I can
decide that I'm arresting the people of
the house and tying them up to defense
of my
base um if you will get in order to
demolish their home or just lock their
front door and don't let them out into
the street their house is on a street
that only Jewish settlers can walk on
and Palestinian cannot so they have to
walk through Windows to yards into the
other side into the Kasa of Kon I think
realizing all of that in a very very
early stage in my
service helped me understood that
someone was lying to me along the way I
didn't feel like I'm protecting anyone I
didn't feel like I'm helping anyone
feeling more safe I feel like I'm
terrorizing people I have um excellent
rights I have health there are cities in
Israel being built for Jews only and
also in the West Bank settlements being
built for Israeli Jews only while
Palestinians are hemmed in unable to
build cities and their homes are being
demolished for lack of permits that are
almost impossible to get um the Israeli
authorities are engaging in forcable
transfer where they remove Palestinian
community in the West Bank to make room
for settlements all of these are part of
the root causes of the violence there's
terrible abuses going on you just have
to listen to what people on the ground
are telling you and adjust accordingly
the Muslim the the Palestinian Muslim
about even the Christian Christian pales
they can't go down these streets these
roads one set of Rights died literally
trying to get to a hospital but they
can't get to it cuz they have to take
these roads that are filled with
checkpoints where the soldiers can
arbitrarily deny you access to the
hospital so many unarmed civilians have
been killed at these checkpoints it's
horrific and the the IDF that's what
they T they they can go ahead and
harass H without any kind of
consequences corre they can harass kill
SE home sees a home no
problem that it's an aparti system and
that's the point when people try to say
it's complicated it's not unless you're
an idiot really it's not complicated
just take yourself you know the uh F the
hanity or some of people you know put
yourself in this position we ask like
and live like they're living try to live
and let's see how far you would AB how
how how You' be like man these
Palestinians are very patient people
right 75 how many years patient the
situation is very simple Israel again
was established through ethnic cleansing
the Israeli soldiers that established
Israel acknowledge going to our village
after Village and either driving the
people out at gunpoint or just straight
up killing them and their women and
their children all right after it was
established the Palestinians still
remain the majority so therefore Israel
established an apartheid system whereby
the Palestinians are treated like second
class
citizens worse than just second class
citizens they're treated as subhuman and
they're painted as subhuman by Israeli
leadership and you look at the polls and
the
data a vast majority of even people
within Israel again don't believe Arabs
are as intelligent don't believe that
they're entitled to equal rights and and
they're not given equal rights and they
are continuously arrested without just
cause imprisoned for years homes taken
away killed in Cold Blood I mean you
look at the West Bank West Bank has no
Hamas all right and yet and they and
they've they have peace agreements with
Israel and despite those agreements
Israel continues to illegally build
settlements within the best bank and
occupy land there and
continuously kill children over the last
week 20 Palestinian children in the West
Bank have been killed by Israel this is
horrific these are war crimes it's not
complicated let's stop justifying and
enabling aggression you've heard of uh
Norman ficklin yes excellent yeah he's
Jewish his family Holocaust Survivors
and when you listen to someone like that
somebody who's invested 40 years I
believe of his life into this and he was
making an example with with what was
just happening and he gave kind of a
something that's not 100% the same but
he gave an example here how uh in
America we're holding certain people
from history that at one time when you
had the Revolt of Nat Turner the
Rebellion the slave rebellion and then
you had the the people like William
Lloyd Garrison and others who were
trying to free the slaves and all the
depression that the slaves were going
through over and over and over and then
William L Garrison and and the like they
kept warning they kept warning kept
warning you know what you're doing to
these people it's wrong it's wrong you
know it's going to come back and then
they had the slave revolt and Norman
ficklin he he ends up um using this and
showing how now people like William
Lloyd Garrison they made statues of him
how they're praised in American history
now I mean what else do you expect and
and actually my friends who are very
much in Pro Israeli circles have even
acknowledged this that are that are in
in the political space once we engage
with them they acknowledge essentially
what we saw happening out of Gaza was no
different than a slave revolt if you
take people you imprison them the people
of Gaza by Israel's own leadership are
living in an open air prison the saying
is if you're born in Gaza you're born
dead see people this is another Point
very important for the lay person
average American or they don't have no
idea
want to just leave they're trapped in
they they can't build they can't go
fishing a certain am from the sea that's
the wrong question I hate when why don't
they just leave it's like why why
doesn't Israel just stop killing them
how about that that's the right question
why doesn't the uh person in jail get
out of the jail exact you can't leave
the jail they're actually trapped
exactly so they're in in an open air
prison Israel actually counts the
calories it only allows so much food in
the country for people to barely survive
97% of the people of Gaza don't have
access to clean drinking water Israel
controls the utilities the the water
they have their own aquafer systems but
Israel blows them up and doesn't allow
them to get the the material to rebuild
so they're starved they're deprived of
Clean Water they're not given the
ability to get out or travel or get a
passport they're treated as
subhuman you take people and you lock
them up and you deprive them of their
basic rights and Liberties and their
ability to survive that's all they want
for so long and eventually you're going
to have a slave rebellion so for people
to act shocked I think is very
disingenuous the other interesting thing
Eddie is that these uh you know after
the attack a lot of these Israelis have
been saying well let's wipe Gaza off the
face of the Earth let's just eliminate
the people of Gaza let's bomb them back
to the Stone Age and it's like okay so
because of one attack that you faced now
you're justifying horrific war crimes
well what about the fact that the
Palestinians have been facing such
horrific attacks for the last 75 years
you don't think they're going to want to
respond with with a level of violence
look we all want peace but you're a liar
or a hypocrite if you think peace can be
achieved with the status quo the status
quo lacks Justice it treats Palestinians
as second class citizens their life is
not sacred in fact Israel continuously
has killed thousands the the data shows
that for every one Israeli killed 20
Palestinians have been killed Israel
kills far more civilians you cannot have
peace absent justice so we need a just
peace we need to change the status quo
it's interesting um you'll see when
anybody who's sincere looks into this
then they start to see like what's
apparent it's it's not something that's
in a gray area that's you know confusing
it's pretty straightforward just put
yourself in that situation and let's see
if you can have someone count your
calories for you uh give you uh a
certain amount of water water dirty
water in control of your airspace your
fishing space like it's pretty much they
control everything but then you hear
people like the Ben shapiros and others
they say Well they're not as the UN and
others call this illegal occupation
someone like him he'll spout this these
lies saying that well Israel pulled out
in 2005 they pulled out they how would
you resp Soul these people the only
people who truly support Israel right
now here either have sold their souls
have been bought and paid for or
genuinely are evil within their heart
they genuinely see the Palestinians as
second class citizens and they don't
value their human life you know the
biggest hypocrisy that irritates me is
when I hear
from American
politicians saying Israel has a right to
defend itself cut the BS out you're not
defending yourself on your bombing
carpet bombing civilian population
you're not defending yourself on in one
day you're killing 500 children and
maybe you would have gotten away with
this 10 20 years ago before social media
really became prevalent but now when you
go on screen and say Israel has a right
to defend itself but the world is
witnessing Israel slaughtering thousands
of children pushing buttons on Jets and
blowing up entire residential buildings
one of my friends in bokeh he messaged
me he said our family building was
bombed 4 22 of our family members were
killed by Israel in one
night so when people say Israel has a
right to defend itself but we see it's
not defending itself it's literally
carpet bombing and killing thousands of
civilians these politicians look bought
and paid for or hypocritical they look
like idiots they look like liars and I
think the world is going to have enough
of this Norman felstein again an expert
academic uh Jew like I said earlier uh
he's somebody's dedicated 40 years when
he was asked this question he was uh
interviewed
and about the human Shields you hear
this a lot and what he said he said look
this is according to uh Professor Norman
fickles team he said look we're not
going to go ahead and look to people who
have an interest IDF or the other group
here they have a an interest so we're
not going to go ahead and take anything
from them but let's look
at others who don't and then he quotes
the agencies the human rights agencies
in Israel he says let's see what they're
reporting uh he starts with that then he
starts with other human rights
organizations such as Human Rights Watch
Amnesty International he he points to
the relating to this question that comes
up often it's a talking point over and
over and over along with the one you
said about defending yourself IDs
reservists who organized and have the BR
breaking the sil let's see what they say
the reports with them uh they say along
with the UN invest investigative body
then go check Norman ficklin on this he
says there's no
evidence to this human shield but
opposite it's the
Palestinians that are being used as
human shield by the IDF this is
mindblowing you will never find any
documentation of so he listed he listed
all his organization he read through all
L the report see people don't read the
reports they don't go and look credible
they look at you know they're listen the
mainstream media again that has its
agenda that cannot be trusted but I
think with the Advent of social media
The Narrative is breaking cuz basically
what you do have is these international
human rights organizations that have
done the documentation and then you have
people on the ground documenting it
themselves and then through social media
we can witness it so you will you won't
find any videos of Palestinian
resistance you know forcing their fellow
countrymen whose support they enjoy they
have the support of the people the
people support the resistance movements
because they're tired of being blown up
by Israel they're tired of being treated
like second class citizens they saw what
happened in the West Bank didn't work
they saw that when the West Bank laid
down their weapons Israel continue to
colonize continue to kill continue to
System of aparti people will not put up
with oppression they will resist and it
is their god-given right now that never
means you intentionally Target children
and and innocent civilians but the
reality is there was a lot of a
propaganda put out to misrepresent what
was happening to misrepresent what
happened in order to dehumanize the
Palestinians to justify the
disproportionate and unjust response but
ultimately the reality is when you look
at the data you will not find uh
Palestinian resistance Fighters using
their fellow countrymen as human Shields
you will find much footage of Israeli
soldiers like cowards hiding behind
children with the weapons using
Children's as human Shields they're the
biggest liars and the biggest Hypocrites
and social media I think is going to
help us uh change the narrative and
debunk this the other thing that I want
to get at is the atrocities Israel is
doing with us tax dollars is so horrific
so
mind-bogglingly wrong immoral dare I say
pure
evil that they cannot handle a free and
open Fair conversation about it so they
always want to get on the offensive and
they want to uh point to Hamas and make
the conversation about condemning Hamas
I'm sick and tired of that because
here's the reality there is no moral
obligation on us As Americans to condemn
Hamas because guess what our government
already has our government's labeled
them mat terrorist organization so if
everyone were to march in the street
tomorrow condemning Hamas it will not
change a thing they don't have our
support they do not have America's
Financial or legal support so our
opinion on them is irrelevant we're not
supporting in them when you don't
support something you have no obligation
to condemn it there's many crimes that
happen all over the world we don't have
to sit and condemn everyone because it
has nothing to do with us however we do
fund Israel's crimes against the
Palestinian people the 2,000 children
that have been killed in Gaza over the
last two weeks we as Americans have
their blood on our
hands and because of that we do have a
moral obligation to condemn Israel
because we fund them so the conversation
should never be about Hamas it always
must be about the group that we are
funding and enabling we must condemn
their actions and we must stop sending
billions of tax dollars that so
desperately needed to save the lives of
children at home we should not be
sending it to kill children abroad and
then this plan will not work for Israel
what do they think what do they think
they're accomplishing they can either
completely Wipe Out the Palestinians and
commit a mass
Holocaust
or if they don't what's going to happen
is every single child child who saw his
sister who saw her brother who saw their
parents blown up in pieces before their
very eyes they will
rightfully want to have armed resistance
against Israel they're creating a new
generation of soldiers to fight them
what do you think now you see and this
was surprising CU from a lot of the
conservative side people who you were
thinking now were aligning more with
Muslim values especially with the whole
alphab movement looking to work together
and really going up against the the woke
culture of cancellation and whatnot and
freedom of speech and now they're
actually
doing what they've been complaining of
as happening to them and now with the
protest and most Muslims like myself and
others really don't follow much of the
the the different groups that are there
are don't even most probably didn't even
know who hamus is it hamus who Hamas
like have no idea right but now they're
trying to lump everybody in like they
supporting these certain groups Shifting
the conversation and now even trying to
ban these protests and and whatnot so
they're attacking the freedom of speech
because most people who are going to the
protest they're just worried about the
kids they're look about the innocent
people who are are dying the people that
are protesting in support of Palestine
are simply protesting for the right of
Palace they're not they're not they're
not protesting for
H they just want here's the crazy thing
but but you see this no I understand
yeah I understand look again the people
protesting for Palestine are simply
protesting for the right of palestin
live for freedom for Li for the right to
live those supporting Israel the
protesting they're supporting Israel's
so-called right to blow up children one
side is protesting for Life the other is
protesting for the right to murder
Palestinian Pro Palestinian protesters
are protesting for the right of
Palestinians to live free of bombing and
free of
apartheid and the pro-israeli supporters
are protesting for Israel's ability to
bomb and kill civilians you've SE you've
always seen a spin put on this when you
had the U right of return March was it
uh this was a few years ago I believe
and you had people in wheelchairs you
had people no they were just there by
the border just protesting you had uh
journalists and elderly young old they
were they were there just just uh trying
to do anything they can to try to uh
create some awareness and whatnot and I
I believe it was like hundred hundreds
hundreds were shot hundreds were killed
you know about this Pro the march of
return uh there was no weapons there was
no arm resistance but they they they
again spun it around they always spin it
somehow they're very I mean because
they're spending let's be clear Israel
propaganda machine is literally spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on
propaganda from talking points to
lobbying to to Media engagement a lot of
the pro-israeli uh uh whether they're
politicians or media personalities are
bought and paid for are funded see
everything I'm doing Pro Palestine and
pro human rights alhamdulillah I'm not
getting $1 for I'm actually
sacrificing work at my Law Firm to do
this and my Law Firm right now we at
Muslim legal Muslim legal.com we've
established two programs to support uh
human rights for the Palestinians the
first is palestin sensor.com we are
documenting
the incidents of uh people advocating
for human rights for Palestinians having
their social media Pages shut down by
the big social media platforms and we're
pushing to get them reinstated and to
challenge those censorship policies
number two is we are offering free legal
representation to anyone who faces
unjust criminal charges because they are
protesting or engaging in Civil
Disobedience we are not getting paid to
do what we do we do it because we
believe in it the the bip Heroes even
the bidens that are speaking out in
sport of Israel it's because of the
financial
benefit or really the dogmatic
extremism that they have they're bought
and paid for they sold their souls I I
want to I want to go into um one uh Ayah
or verse from the verba and word of God
Almighty the Quran it really strikes
home for me here and this is in the
second chapter of the Quran where God
Almighty Allah is saying in the meaning
which is and when it is said to them
make not Mischief on the earth they say
we are peacemakers you know we're the
ones making peace verily they are the
ones who make Mischief but they perceive
it not what do you think when you hear
this Ayah this was one of the first aat
I posted look right now I'm going to
tell you whether you're a Muslim or not
if you want peace to get through the
traumatizing aspect of witnessing
imagine this we are traumatized and
we're not sleeping just witnessing on
our phones the horrific atrocities Happ
to Israel when I'm home with my child
and and I see my 2-year-old daughter
come and yell daddy daddy and come and
hug me my heart aches because I remember
all the children that I saw
Palestinians that have been killed in
Cold Blood with our tax dollars all the
fathers will never be able to hug their
children again all the children will
never be able to hug their parents again
we're getting traumatized just
witnessing it imagine the trauma they're
getting facing it
and and I think to cope with this to
find strength we need to return to the
Quran so I encourage everyone Muslim and
notm Muslim read the Quran read the
translation of the Quran ponder it has
answers to all of this this was one of
the first verses and if they are told do
not cause corruption on Earth they say
we are but peacemakers no they are
indeed the corruptors and and we see
this they go on TV saying Israel has a
right to defend itself so when you
imagine that you said somebody's getting
attacked okay and they're just defending
themselves Israel is not defending
itself Israel is literally killing
thousands of civilians and even this
whole thing about evacuation uh they
allegedly dropped leaflets saying okay
evacuate North Gaza well first of all
Israel bombed the very evacuation routes
it told people to take it was a death
trap
secondly evacuation is not a nice
humanitarian thing evacuation is is the
definition of ethnic cleansing they're
basically saying we want to take over
this area so get out because if you stay
we're going to kill you that's a that's
not Humanity that's illegal it's immoral
it's evil so they go and they say we're
but peacemakers but they're the ones
that are killing and watch how much
there is footage of Israelis and and
whether it's your average um citizen or
their government leadership that is po
openly advocating for Exterminating the
Arabs it's horrific if you look at this
uh term anti-semitic let's get into that
for a moment I'll show a clip here you
actually have someone who's an Israeli
people here are called anti-semitic what
is your response to that as an Israeli
Jew well it's a trick we always use it
when from Europe somebody is criticizing
Israel then we bring up the Holocaust
when in this country people are
criticizing Israel then there are
anti-semitic and the organization is
strong and has a lot of money and the
the ties between Israel and the American
EST Jewish establishment are very strong
and they are strong in this country as
you know they have power which it's okay
they're talented people and they have
power money and media and other things
and their attitude is Israel my country
right or wrong the
identification and they are not ready to
hear criticism who actually admits that
this is used just to it it is used look
one one argument I I I don't care for
much is when people say oh well we're
Semitic too so we can't be anti-semitic
it's true we are Semitic too but I'm not
going to waste my time debating that
with regardless of the terms when it
comes down to it you know are we being
anti-jewish by condemning Israel
absolutely not and unfortunately the
Israeli propaganda machine is trying to
say when you criticize Israel you it's
because you don't like Jews no that has
nothing to do in fact we we stand in
solidarity with countless honorable
Jewish men and women that say in my name
don't kill Palestinians do you make
distinction between zionists and Je of
course so I absolutely distinguish
between Zionist Isis that's why I call
them I don't call them zionists I call
them Zion Isis that's what they are with
all due respect Isis was this horrific
group that wanted to kill everyone who
did not share 100% their dogma and they
caused a lot of corruption on this Earth
and they killed many civilians zionists
want to take over this land and get rid
of all of those that don't share their
religion it's horri horrific it's
criminal but we absolutely distinguish
between
zionists and Jews many of our Jewish
brothers and sisters stand in solidarity
with us we're not hating Israel because
they're Jewish we're hating them because
they're committing horrific crimes
against humanity and the reality is
there's nothing wrong with the idea of
having a Jewish state but you cannot
have a Jewish state if the majority of
the people who live in that land are not
Jewish and you're going to treat them
differently then I'm against that I'm
also against having a Muslim state where
the majority the people that are living
there are not Muslim and you're going to
treat them as second class citizens it's
not right you're seeing people come out
of the closet also some that might have
not necessarily spoken out on some of
the verses in the Bible and now you'll
see I don't know if you see some of the
the rabbis who are actually and if you
contrast that with Islam The Rules of
Engagement where the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him he
clearly stated that one cannot attack uh
non-combatants women children elderly
and all the rest will put this up here
very clear I don't know if you've seen
some of the rabbis yeah I posted it put
the clip up Eddie I
mean anyone who is merciful over vicious
people ultimately will become vicious
towards merciful people there is no
permission from the Torah to have any
Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on
anybody
why because if a person understands what
is War and why you're fighting you know
put it up on this on this video
literally a a Zionist Israeli extremist
Rabbi saying do not even have mercy on
the children and they're quoting their
holy text again I don't believe imagine
if a Muslim IM was out there saying
something like this which we don't you
can't find that in Islam there was
nobody who can say that because the text
says don't killing women and that's and
that's exactly what have mercy and
that's exactly what if they go towards
peace go to peace 100% this is the Quran
right% and that's and that's I mean
thank God some hostages some elderly
women Israelis were released uh within
the past 24 hours and they went on the
media and they said listen our captors
told us don't worry we follow the Quran
we will not harm you that's what they
were saying that's literally what they
were told but that's opposite what we're
getting from the well and that's why the
media was so they like shoot this is
breaking because again the narrative
they want to do is paint Hamas as if
it's like Isis and that they just hate
the Israelis because they're Jewish and
they just want to kill all the Jews in
the world that's not what it's about
Hamas formed I think it was 30 40 years
after the establishment of Israel as a
direct resistance to this uh subjugation
of the Palestinian people by Israel but
Ron Paul was saying this is a creation
of Israel yeah I mean that's a theory
that goes out it's not one that I
necessarily promote or Advocate some say
Israel funded them some say Israel
created them to create descent between
there but if you speak to the people
I've spoken to many people from Gaza on
the ground and they say listen um this
is a resistance movement that has the
support of the local population and an
easy way out a comp out and some of my
friends really care for Palestinian
children they really do um and they're
very staunch on the sort of EXT uh
conservative side they're like well
listen this is between Hamas and Israel
and and you know just we they just got
to get rid of Hamas and and protect the
Palestinian people what they're not
understanding is the Palestinian people
voted for Hamas years ago because they
were tired of the Israeli occupation
Hamas is a direct result of Israeli
occupation I'm going tell you straight
up right now if in America a if China
came in and decided to take over our
land to take over Florida all right to
take over the United States to kill
entire cities right to drive Americans
from their homes and then to Corner
Americans to live in
slums you don't think we would create
our own American Hamas and its Point
wouldn't it be to kill the Chinese
because they're Chinese it would be to
fight back to call for freedom and
Justice and I think the majority of the
resistance would be legitimate
resistance but guess what you better bet
that they some of them would probably
make mistakes and that that's
horrific but it would be nowhere near
that atrocities and the crimes
that uh China would have done by
invading our land and imagine then China
just keeps wanting to talk about our
resistance movement that's not what the
conversation should be about the
resistance movement would not exist
without something to resist what are
they resisting it's not the presence of
Jews Jews have lived under Muslim rule
Co coexisted peacefully for hundreds of
years what they're resisting is
occupation if you want to end the
resistance you must end the occupation
why do you think it's so hard for we
don't have a problem we say all life is
precious life rather be Jewish Israeli
whoever all you know Islam condemns you
know killing of any innocent human
beings obviously obviously but then on
the other side you see them looking at
the painting the picture as their
animals R and please put up the quotes
of what top Israel leadership have been
saying about the Palestinians painting
them as animals subhuman wanting to
flatten Gaza kill them that's the crazy
thing that it's it's it's entrenched
within them because they realize they
cannot exist if the Palestinians are
there they cannot exist as a true
democracy they have to get rid of them
how do you get rid of a people unless
you really think that they're subhuman
that they're barbaric that they're not
worthy of life but this is what Hitler
actually did and now they're calling
them Nazis but then this is what the
Nazis the Hitler they he had a special
unit of people in the propaganda and his
media and that is doing exactly what
they're doing now to the 100% that's
what's ironic they were calling them
rats at that time that's that's what's
ironic isn't that ironic so the one who
was uh oppressed became the oppressor
became the oppressor this is just
mindblowing it's insane and that's why
you actually do have many Holocaust
Survivors or the children thereof I mean
Norman filstein is a great example of
that M yes many others who've said
listen our parents our grandparents went
through the Holocaust and now were
witnessing Israel doing a Holocaust in
Gaza these are Jews now these are Jewish
hoca who lying with Palestinians this is
something that people should look at
like they're putting their neck on the
lines let's just value human life
equally that's what we're calling for
let's stop the bombing and again
stopping the bombing is the first step
but you can't then just go back to the
status quo where you have people living
in an open air prison calorie counting
them not allowing them open
concentration camps denying them
citizenship denying them the right to
vote and that's why listen I will
challenge anyone to accept the solution
I will challenge their leadership you
you're about a democracy but they won't
because it's entrenched within their
actual laws in their country be a true
democracy make it one person one vote
doesn't matter if they're Jewish or
Palestinian equal rights for all that's
what we're calling for that's what we're
calling for one person one vote equal
rights for all regardless of your
ethnicity or your religion if you live
there that's it that's what we're
calling for and that's what they're
against how can you be against a system
where everyone is equal under the law
you're on the wrong side of History if
you're against that we're calling for
equality and Liberty they're calling for
death and apartheid Our intention here
I'm really um you know wanting to
sincerely help people to see the
hypocrisy here and to help stop you know
be a small voice to try to create some
awareness to help stop the the murder
the children you know the kids uh you
know this is what's uh the innocent
human beings and and anybody with a
heart if it's alive I mean if you care I
mean God Almighty the Creator is not
going to
support a group of people to be unjust
to be unfair to be massacring innocent
children it doesn't make any sense and
here's my next question I'll ask you a
couple more we'll come to an end you say
Zionist we understand link back to some
of these people um that we're talking
about but then you have it's a strange
relationship really the Christians
who are also now supporting this and
they call themselves Christians Z this
yes it's it's ironic so you you have a
couple issues with that I think number
one is that they have turned their
back on their Christian Palestinian
brothers and sisters you have videos of
Palestinian Christians getting Spit On
by the occupying settler
Israelis you have one of the oldest
churches in the world getting being
bombed by Israel you have so many
Palestinian Christians being killed and
oppressed and treated second class
citizens by the Israelis so they're
being persecuted themselves you know it
goes back to Dogma I think the ironic
thing is they believe that there must be
this Israeli State for the Messiah to
return and then what is he going to do
ironically he's going to fight the Jews
himself so they're setting up the Jews
so they they want him to succeed so they
could set them up it's it's insane it's
bizarre it's bizarre I would say let's
take a step out of dogma and that's why
Islam is so beautiful it's it's a pure
faith of natural reason it is really
isn't dogmatic it's not that you have to
really just believe something that
doesn't make sense that's irrational
what does Islam say that your heart
should grieve when you see a Jewish
child or a Muslim child or a Christian
child killed we saw the world up in arms
when there was the false rumor atrocity
propaganda and this propaganda was used
to dehumanize the Palestinians to
justify the actual war crimes by Israel
against them where they claimed 40
babies were beheaded never happened
never happened but you know what 2,000
Palestinian children have been killed by
Israel many of whom are babies that have
been decapitated by American made and
funded bombs where where is the outrage
for that the world we will never for
forget the outrage at 40 fake babies and
the silence at the thousands of babies
and children killed with our tax dollars
we must be ashamed and we will answer to
God mark my words the day will come and
God may ask each and every one of us
what did we
do and I do not know how the bidens
certainly not the
Netanyahu will stand before God the
Quran says whoever kills an innocent
Soul doesn't classify religion just any
nefs any person any Soul whoever kills
an innocent Soul it's as if they have
killed all humanity and whoever saves a
life it is as if they have saved all
Humanity we are working to save lives we
do want an end to conflict we want to
just peace we want peace but we know
there cannot be peace without justice so
we want Justice for the Palestinians and
peace because that's the only way to
achieve peace they're calling for more
Bloodshed and more violence they will
have to answer to God and Allah says in
the Quran do not think God is unaware of
what the wrongdoers are
doing he's just delaying them to to a
day when their eyes will stare in horror
when all the violence all the evil they
Justified is played before them and they
will have to answer to God for that as
for those I mean my heart Grieves for
all the Innocents killed do not lose
hope God says do not be weary do not
lose hope we have tested previous
Nations until even he said in fact you
think you'll enter Paradise without
being tested like the previous Nations
they were Afflicted with trials and
tribulations and were so shaken until
the messenger and those around him said
where is the help of God surely it is
near and in another verse he says that
he allows you to go through such
hardship that he may take from you
Martyrs those women those children those
innocent
civilians killed in Cold Blood while
they're just huddled as a family trying
to survive the bombing of the
night those are the martyrs that God is
taking they're enjoying Paradise forever
but the damnation is on those who
enabled their wrongful murder that's
good we we'll finish we'll conclude on
that um any person it seems like if
you're void of God you use religion to
kind of justify it now that's one thing
you know um then you're following the
devil but if you're if you have any iota
of Faith or belief in God this is
totally unacceptable 100% any kind of
moral code anything this is just totally
truly religious Muslim Christian or Jew
you'd be against this violence and you'd
be speaking out against it may God make
us sources of Peace in this land and
Justice not sources of corruption amen
thank you my brother God
bless brothers and sisters we've all had
loved ones that passed away a mother a
father a brother sister a close family
member but one of the mercies of our
Dean is that with the right intention we
can go ahead and continue to do good
deeds on our loved ones behalf and what
greater of a continuous Good Deed Sakia
than investing on their behalf in the
dean Center a mid and mega dawa Center
that will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go ahead and
visit the Deen show.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum